let's go with a little bit of good news
but also kind of bad news
and i'll start with a question
uh
joe biden recently appeared on cnn um
mark how many viewers do you think they
attracted to that spectacle with the
president of these united states so
because i'm an insane media junkie i
believe it was 1.42 million 1.42 oh fox
news says 1.2 okay sorry
you were giving you were giving too much
to joe biden i was quoting cnn math yeah
well so we have the story from fox news
cnn's brian stouter avoids network's
poorly watched biden town hall and
reliable sources media show cnn's prime
time event averaged only 1.2 million
viewers finishing in third place behind
fox news and
msnbc think about what this means that
doesn't mean what you think it means
my initial reaction was wow people would
rather watch the daily fox or msnbc as
opposed to the president give a town
hall
man biden must suck
well the better way to put it is people
don't care about biden they would rather
watch their their their cannon fodder
for the culture war
that's that's what's actually important
biden is irrelevant in the culture war
he was not trump therefore he got votes
but right now we're seeing that for one
okay here's the good news cnn is in
crisis you know they can't even get more
than they can they can't even get a
couple million viewers off the president
himself that's also indicative of what's
happening to this country with fox and
msnbc doing better people want the fight
yeah no i think that's absolutely true
but at the same time i mean cnn has
become msnbc i mean there's no
difference there for a long time in
cable news there was they differentiated
themselves fox is a conservative network
msnbc was a liberal network and cnn was
they were the liberal media but they
were at least trying to like you know
present themselves as the acceptable
alternative that could be shown in
airports um now i mean they're they're
they're deranged i mean their time
network i mean their prime time
programming i mean it's not really in
tone and substance different from msnbc
in terms of their political till don
lemon may be one of the stupidest people
i have ever seen hey cuomo is also on
that network so sure you have to hey hey
you're insulting stupid people now do
you remember when don lemon asked if the
missing malaysian airline may have been
sucked into a black hole yeah i remember
that that's true story good stuff that's
that that's that's cnn desperate for
ratings
he's like but is it possible i know it's
preposterous but is it preposterous yes
and people are like oh come on tim he
was just have a little bit of fun and
i'm like dude
if you want to speculate what could have
happened to a plane a black hole
swallowing it is the stupidest possible
thing to even joke about because a black
hole wouldn't be able to get anywhere
near the plant without destroying
substantially more than just one
airplane but that's cnn for you these
are the trusted name and news tim i mean
they're the ones that youtube trusts
more than anyone else they're the ones
that they're
they get put on the top of the list they
get shown to everyone
so years ago david foster wallace wrote
this really interesting essay about
conservative talk radio for the atlantic
back in the day supposedly wallace was
an interesting guy uh supposedly he was
a big rush limbaugh fan i don't know if
he agreed with limbo's politics but like
he just liked listening to radio and he
made this observation in the piece where
he was talking all these talk radio
people about how they would harp on the
same subjects over and over again um
about how they compared talk radio and
the ideas that the way they talked about
things to
um you know regular radio where it's
like look just because the morning dj
played the hit song doesn't mean that
you as the evening dj don't get to play
the hit song everybody wants to hear the
hit song and i think cable news has
carried that approach forever like the
malaysia airlines thing is a classic
example like
they just you know clung to this story
because it was getting cnn meager
ratings at the time and then they were
in a slow news cycle for a couple of
weeks and so they just pumped that story
so you get don lemon who's already you
know has the brains god gave trout you
know saying things about black holes
eventually right he ran out of stuff to
talk about but they're still clinging to
this model where they just say the same
things over and over and over again and
the uh media environment isn't even what
it was 10 years ago where you have so
many other alternatives you want to hear
a new and fresh perspective you've got a
million other things that you can hear
rather than you know one of three or
four broadcast networks and they just
haven't woken up to that reality it's
crazy i think what they realized is that
with the internet and the
infinite
you know field of choices
that they need to find their
specific audience that will stick to
them and why it used to be that there
were very few channels to watch you know
we had four major networks or whatever
and then all of a sudden you have the
cable channels and cnn was getting
massive viewership just by virtue of
being 24 hour news i mean they were they
were the original you know 24-hour news
channel so they had the ratings people
would turn it on in airports and hotels
and they worked these deals out
with the internet people can choose to
go read whatever news they want yeah and
they can choose the news that's actually
comforting to them and they do which is
bad so cnn realized we better start
pandering as much as possible to a
certain crowd and when trump came out
the stuff that made him the most money
was not liking trump so they said we
need opinion guys who don't like trump
so now they're msnbc
how do you recover from that though
because when trump's gone what do you
got left well that's it and the other
part of that story though was the
credibility they lost during that time
because they went so hard after trump
they went down say a trump russia
collusion rabbit hole that you know i
just don't even know how that you can
even call yourself a journalist after
publishing that stuff that's crazy for
so many years i mean and again they just
are like buffaloing through all this
like like new media doesn't exist like
you know the fact that they have been
undermining trust on on the like the
major story that occupied a news cycle
for three years turned out to be false i
mean they're just pretending they win
awards for it and they attack people
that call them on on it the people who
from the very beginning were like
they're full of crap there's no evidence
there's no documents there's nothing to
prove their story i think they were
vilified i think the new york times won
a pulitzer for um
for their trump russia reporting in what
was it like march of 2019 and the
mueller report happened like three
months later i mean like literally
everything they just won a polisher for
was like invalidated it's madness and
yet they just pretend that it it these
things aren't happening like i look i
mean this is a great show i'm a fan of
the show i'm here tonight because i
enjoy it but i've also got a book remote
i'm here because you guys are legit
competition to the cable news you've got
a million subscribers on on youtube
cable news people don't think that way
they're still kind of you know in the
dark about this and it's and it's
because they're so egotistical they
don't understand americans are hungry
for other perspectives they don't
understand we have alternatives and they
don't understand they're frankly getting
better information elsewhere they're
also you know uh public companies so
they have to make profits this company
will make profits because it's awesome
and well designed but it's not about the
profits it's about the message
i get invited on fox news a lot more
than i that used to i've been i speak be
invited on periodically for like
specific stories now it just feels like
the guys over at fox will hit me up you
know twice a month or whatever and be
like hey do you want to come on this
segment
you know i just did a segment the other
day and i was thinking to myself
afterwards like why am i even doing this
anymore like they hit me up and they're
like yo we'll send it a van it's really
easy it's it's 10 minutes you just pop
in and i'm like yeah sure why not right
and then i this time around i got out of
the truck they have these satellite vans
or they're not satellite fans they're
they're cell bonding vans and i was just
like why am i even bothering going on
this
you know to to to talk for a few minutes
and i'll tell you like my thought
process was
shows like this
it's raw
it's just a couple hours we talk i do
have a bunch of stories i'm like i want
to get to and i don't want i don't i
want to make sure we don't just beat a
dead horse and talk about too much over
and over again so i'll be like okay
let's you know try and change the
subject on this you know so there is
some structure to it
but for the most part if a conversation
happens conversation happens you go on
fox news and they're like
some days they're like it's going to be
five minutes and they talk to me for 10
and i'm like what's going on like
they're still talking to me and then
they were like you were doing so well
they just kept going with it and i'm
like i got a deadline i got to be inside
and there are some times so they're like
it's a 10-minute segment and they're
like oof and they just cut it off after
the first sentence because they don't
want you to say what you're saying or
they don't like what you're saying and
i'm just like people don't want this
people don't want you know
i think there's i think this is why you
see
the key demo ratings for these big
networks are in the gutter their overall
ratings are good if you go by key demo
we absolutely beat all of the big cable
shows
i mean for a number of years now i just
refused to do interviews with the
mainstream media there's there's nothing
to win a lot of people you don't get
that engagement you don't get that kind
of honest real
uh kind of conversations that could
really delve into issues that people
could get to know you from that people
could interact and engage with you like
here i got the comment section open
because your voice matters i i want to
interact with you people back there they
have makeup rooms they they live in this
kind of world of delusion where they
think they're all mighty and powerful
and they have the money to pretend that
they are but at the end of the day it's
just pretend for them well i'll push
back a little and and simply say that
you know for the time being
a lot of these organizations still do
bring a level of sort of resources if
nothing else and or you know some degree
of professionalism in terms of editing
and other things that most you know
online media outlets
uh that are competing on new media
outlets haven't quite gotten caught up
to some of them have more of them will
we will get to that point um you know so
they still do some good work and but and
they're still very influential within
you know the a lot of narrow circles
that matter republican congressmen are
watching fox fox news and and that
matters you know trump is watching fox
news but i would push back and i would
say that uh when when we're talking
about ethics the mainstream media has a
very lower quality than people online
look at wmds look at the lies that they
told them the effects that they've been
having on people that cost people to die
and republicans care more about the
opinion of the new york times than they
do of the opinion of their constituents
yes yeah and but this is the thing one
thing about trump i will say is i think
trump woke up republicans specifically
and americans more generally to the
problems of getting mixed up with the
media um trump was the first you know
sort of
large public figure that basically said
you know what i don't have to do i don't
have to leak the story the new york
times i can leak this story to breitbart
or whatever and it'll have just as much
an effect and that was like a really
threatening realization to them the fact
that he could go through alternative
media and frequently did and that was i
think what made the media hate them a
lot but you know going back to what you
were saying earlier i mean it is totally
true the way that the media has become
so adversarial and openly so politically
i tell this to ordinary people all the
time this happens i'll talk to people
they will they'll just because i you
know know people out in the hinterlands
they're like you're you know a
journalist someone from the chicago
tribune or new york times called me and
they wanted to talk about this thing
that's happening in my business and i'm
like 95 percent of them like absolutely
not do not talk about you know the story
of mayo gate
uh no so uh let's tell the story of mayo
gate
there was a uh tweet from the north
carolina gop
it was a quote from a story about a
business that said inflation's really
bad
we're spending 200 bucks a week more in
mayonnaise
and so all of a sudden because it came
from republicans democrats huffington
post slate i don't know a bunch of these
i think it was late a bunch of these
lefty lefty outlets picked up the story
and said
that the restaurant owner was lying
about the cost of mayonnaise to make joe
biden look bad
they did this ridiculous math where they
were like if the consumer price index is
up 5
200 would mean that they're spending
three thousand seven hundred dollars per
week on mayonnaise as i say a month is
200 bucks per week on menus and so you
know what i did um journalism i
called the restaurant
and i said is this you know
such-and-such restaurant i'm looking for
the owner and i said i'm one of the
partners and i said i saw a story where
um there's a statement from one of your
you know uh principals that you were
spending 200 a week more on mayonnaise
and you went oh yeah yeah we we go
through about you know i can't remember
the exact numbers but he's like we use
these big five gallon drums about 10 of
them
they've jumped up about 18 bucks per per
uh per you know canister or whatever so
you know do the math it's like 180 bucks
200 bucks you rise it up and i was like
oh
yeah why do you use so much mayonnaise
oh it's it's we use it for everything
it's it's for you know people put on
their sandwiches of course we use it
make salad dressings it's used in
recipes so we go through quite a bit of
it and i was like what's your
restaurant's capacity it's 250 and i'm
like okay so if you're hitting near
capacity or have capacity everybody gets
a side of mayo or coleslaw or something
on their sandwich yeah going through
mayonnaise but they just made up a
response accuse this guy of lying
and that's why you know
like the guy i ended up getting a call
back from someone else there who was
just like i can't believe this is
happening we didn't say anything
political
and i'm like this is why you don't talk
to the press i'm actually getting i've
been getting hit up to do shows from
people and uh shout out to clint russell
and bob murphy econ uh but
i'm concerned even just youtubers
because if someone does an edited show
like i'm already ridiculous on an
unedited live show if someone wants to
take me out of context they could
destroy the way i seem so even like
legit youtube channels that edit their
stuff i'm warning signs go off when they
ask me so as someone who's a 20 plus
year veteran of you know major news
organizations this is something i will
say that has been a huge shift in the
last five or ten years with this
milkshake ducking thing that did not
used to happen
and now all of a sudden if a private
citizen finds themselves in the
crosshairs of a national political story
and it cuts against what the media wants
they will destroy them do you want to
explain the milkshake duck thing so um
i don't even remember the actual origins
of the meme somebody would have to like
look that up for me but but basically
it's like internet speak for you know
taking you know going through a person's
like social media history and trying to
find you know something to um discredit
them um when they become a matter when
when they become the center of public
the original meme was something to do
with like a guy who created a comic or
something that everyone loved trying to
be a nazi or something like that yeah i
can't remember exactly but but there was
that remember the classic example i
think was who's that guy like asked a
question in a debate that was wearing a
sweater oh yeah yeah ken bone yeah
everyone was so enamored with him or
whatever and then like two days later
you know everyone's like digging up the
fact that he had said some you know off
color thing on reddit once upon a time
this is a the milkshake duck is from
ben ward yeah aka pixelated boat on
twitter
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time